اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم عشيه الذكرى الاولى
للحرب بايدن يزور كيف استمرار الدعم
العسكري والاقتصادي لها تحدث عن انشاء
تحالف من المحيط الاطلسي الى الهادئ
للدفاع عنها
رساله مهمه واشاره قويه على دعم
الاوكرانيين بينما اكدت روسيا ان زياره
تمت بعد حصوله على ضمانات لامنه
عدد قتلى زلزال في تركيا يتجاوز واحد
واربعين الفا وسلطات التركيه تعلن وقف
البحث عن احياء تحت الانقاض باستثناء
ولايتي كهرمان مراش وهاتيه في حين عبرت
مساعده اليونيسف الشمال السوريه من باب
السلامه شمال حلب
السلطات التونسيه تستدعي رئيس البرلمان
المنحل راشد الغنوشي للتحقيق حركه النهضه
تقول ان السلطه الانقلاب في تونس زجت
بالقضاء والمؤسسات الامنيه في السياسه
والاتحاد العامه التونسي للشغل يدعو
لتعبئه شعبيه في مواجهه السلطه
على خطه تويتر شركه ميتال الملكه لفيسبوك
وانستجرام تتيح لمستخدمها الحصول على
علامه التحقق الزرقاء مقابل اشتراك
المدفوع وسيكون ذلك متاحا في استراليا
ونيوزيلندا هذا الاسبوع ذكر قال ان الميزه
الجديده تهدف الى زياده المصداقيه والامان
عبر المنصتين الى اللقاء